I've met a lot of fighters and I
interviewed a lot of fighters in my life
you are
I think the tallest fighter quits go
pretty is is big yeah
but how tall are you 6 foot 6 6 4 7
yeah the air is changed I see that you
had Mike Tyson on your show before I've
had Mike Tyson I've had a lot of
fighters on over the years Evander
Holyfield's been here and they're not as
tall as you people I could easily be
[Laughter]
because there's you know I can I'm
actually taller than some of them and as
we all know if you're a little taller
than someone you can beat them every
time yeah it would seem that way no it
is not it's so funny to me nothing more
nothing less true I am 6 for about 190
pounds and I've been around amazing
fighters who if I didn't know any better
and I'd had a few pints the illusion I
would do the illusion if I think I could
take that guy they would murder me with
their small finger it is the case
they're trained they're trained like the
instincts of these guys is phenomenal by
the development of the heavyweight
division
you know from Tyson 5 foot something and
now six foot something is phenomenal
right they're big guys there are big
guys and heavy hitters right now if I
came at you and let's and that's you
know what
how many secured you go and you know but
if I came at you what would your
assessment be would it be ordered
where's my weakness you know this is the
testicle assess the coup know if you can
find him you're welcome to
[Applause]
you are a huge huge massive star in the
United Kingdom just a massive star you
can't go anywhere what's it like when
you are you recognized in the United
States you're becoming a bigger star but
no I'm not just happy to be here they
think I'm a basketball or I play NFL
something like that and sometimes we
play along to it you know like I just
told them I tore my ACL and right now
now some people if you're into boxing
you'll know because the heavyweight
championship of the world title is well
renowned it's a big title - yeah yeah
and I've captured it and we're trying to
secure the last one item oh yeah well if
you can unite all of those different
belts an incredible feat yeah is this
something that can add to the legacy and
it will do well for the sport boxing as
well when you fight this is unusual you
fight in front of last couple of fights
eighty to ninety thousand people watch
you fight what are the downsides to
fighting in front of a crowd that's that
large it's just no one likes
embarrassment no elects failure and
especially you can use to it trust me
I'm adjusted to recover just and you're
there's people there and they see you
fail and you're like whatever it just
becomes your thing yeah trying to avoid
yeah in front of 89,000 you find that
actually that is a motivating factor
when you're fighting is I don't want to
look bad in front of these people 100%
and especially with that last fight that
you showed against Yanks cry that was
the first thing that went through my
head because that was actually the first
time I boxed in front of a bigger
audience and it was exactly that that
motivate in factor I didn't want to lose
in front of so many people kept me going
when times got tough you you've taken I
mean not a lot cuz you're an incredible
fighter and very great defensively but
when you get hit hard in the head what's
going anything going through your mind
at that moment there first of all
there's everything you just go to
another planet for a while but then you
come back and and what's how can you
motivate yourself out of a moment like
that it's interesting because this the
last thing that you get taught to get
hit in when your flour and your back
there's no coach that will come into the
gym and tell you alright today I'm going
to hit you with a baseball bat
I'm gonna knock you out and I want you
to train yourself to get up yeah it
becomes a situation where it's fight or
flight if you're gonna get up and
continue or you don't have it in you and
you early find out on the night you're
in the ring and I've been down before in
that fight they showed I was down I was
out but luckily I had that fight in me I
got up and continued and was victorious
and now yeah there was a moment there
you get knocked down and you can see
that you're you're trying to get your
bearings so what really happened is
actually slipped you know look look look
like you guys you and I'm gonna keep on
saying that I thought everyone in know
what believe it no no it's true you
slept in you fell against his club
you